I'm your host Neil degrass Tyson and I'm
with Coen Jo colen welcome to Star Talk
did I pronounce your name right Jo Colin
but and Jo most people get Jo wrong so
you're you're already ahead of the game
no I'm only half okay because I did
better than others in that and worse
than the other all right no that makes
me dead even I think I got you on to
just ask me these questions you're going
to be S of the every man person out
there because we get questions and and
for this particular show we've called
together all the questions on time
travel cuz that's what this show has
been about and I've not seen these
questions in advance but you've reviewed
them from Facebook and Twitter and every
other way people have access to us so
fire on oh yeah so this this one this
next one is from uh Google Plus like
even better I never met Google Plus even
better than Google just a little bit
better so a Mr plus ask a little more
charged a little more charged um this
question comes from Frasier Kane of the
website Universe today and it's a
question I've also wonder many times
doesn't the fact that there are no time
travelers now prove that time travel
will never be invented in the
future yeah that's an excellent point
and I've always thought about that
because I said to myself in fact if you
watch the TV the CBS sitcom The Big Bang
Theory uh in the roommate contract
of I know you got to be totally in the
show for this but uh in the roommate
contract that stipulated that if
I if I'm getting the details of it wrong
the sense of it is right if they'll
still be very excited if any one of them
invents a time machine in the future
they have to go back to that moment that
they're reading that phrase in the
roommate contract to show up in the room
and so so they're going through the
contract and then they pause for a
moment no okay we have you know you're
not the one who invents the time machine
in the future that's the ultimate like
let's agree to meet back here 10 years
from now but it's at the same time it's
awesome exactly and so I think that's a
that's a pretty good argument and I
don't have a rebuttal to that but know
what if people are hiding it what if
people have come back but are not
telling people for some reason because
they don't want to give something away
there's a quote I think it was from R
doll but others perhaps have said it
that the only secret that can be kept
between two people is when one of them
is
dead so I'm pretty sure that if a time
machine were out there people would have
figured that one out it's been rumored
that the the reason why the Titanic sank
is because in the future they invented a
time machine and everyone wanted to go
back to the Titanic to see the iceberg
when it hits and then it overloaded the
Titanic and it sank right oh well now
I'm convinced so there's the evidence
you're looking for evidence that's hard
hardcore evidence so uh that's a pretty
good one yeah and it may it might be
that your time travel machine can only
take you into the future and then you
don't have these paradoxes of killing
your grandmother and then you're never
born to go back Back to the Future yeah
yeah exactly CU there's a movie too
coming out called Looper or Loopers that
with Joseph Gordon Le and Bruce Willis
and he goes back in time he's like an
assassin that goes back in time and he
goes back and he's scheduled to kill
himself so he has to like figure out
what to do about it you know what's
interesting all these TV shows they have
people going back and killing people all
you have to do wa all you have to do is
pick a time where two of your ancestors
who mated produced one of your ancestors
and all you have to do is prevent them
from mating you don't have to kill
anybody just just just your great great
great great great grandparents prevent
him from meeting you would have never
been born that's all just enough of the
killing right right forget the Blood and
Guts and so it doesn't take much to
completely alter the path of who's alive
and who was never born and who was never
conceived in this world yeah um all
right next question here comes from
Facebook um it's